[Music]
on the next rick and morty oh my god
what are these things do i look like i
know last thing i remember i was
in a cave looking at some wet egg and oh
that probably did it i told you not to
look at that egg
it was too wet you don't get to tell me
what to look at i've seen your
couch they're face hugging parasites i
don't think their society's gonna be
that hard to navigate
okay yeah this might be a little harder
than i thought catch a new episode next
sunday at 11
30. holy sh they've got an m m store
only an adult swim
it started out as like we wanted to just
do like an anthology the difficulty with
it was
who wants to watch stories when you know
that they don't matter we wanted one off
so we do interdimensional cable not some
uptight overwritten so how do you make
the stories matter
and we felt like what if they're trapped
in an anthology episode and what does
that mean it's a story device
literally just started having fun in
quotes the word fun
with meta structural stuff a literal
literary device quite literally
metaphorically containing us
rick represents limitless potential you
can do anything and it's like yes you
can and that's a trap and you can keep
them in that forever
i don't like how meta this is getting
rich shut up morty i think it's gonna be
a favorite episode of mine but i'd be
the first to say
like the story train itself
it got away from us i beg your pardon
you know jesus he's a cool guy he looks
great
god damn god damn i already did this i'm
terrified of old men
ripping off their shirts to show that
they've been training a lifetime to kick
your ass
jesus the tickets please guy is cut he
he's he's got those things
oop bomb gutters that's what people call
them what are they the grossest
phrase i've ever heard in my life
whatever that means i want it
the combination of the words disgusting
and yet something to aspire towards
it bespeaks of a volume whose is being
guttered i
i your own you are like 90 pum gutter i
don't
where is it guttering to disgusting
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my rick and morty season
episode 7 trailer video they're doing a
big alien parody so we'll break it down
there's a bunch of easter eggs if you're
new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the rick
and morty videos we're doing a merch
giveaway to
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what your
favorite episode of the show is
on the video the title of the episode is
promortius which is a reference to
prometheus because they're visiting what
rick calls a facehugger society so
whatever happened to this race it seems
like the facehuggers have been part of
their culture for a long time
you could take that as a sort of call
back to the unity episode during season
two where she'd taken over the entire
planet for a while when rick shows up
with morty and summer
reunited with her and then everything
just goes completely sideways
if you find a room full of eggs don't
shy away from it give one of them a
shake
based on some of the other season 4
trailer footage from earlier this year
it kind of seems like that's also the
direction things go
with this facehugger society they arrive
and are almost completely taken over by
the facehugger parasites and rick
suddenly remembers
being in a cave looking at some wet egg
and then suddenly remembers the plot of
all the alien movies and it dawns on him
yep that'll do it staring at the wet egg
in the cave
in this trailer they don't say why
they've come to this planet but in the
other trailer footage they released
earlier this year we saw summer dressed
in robes making it look like the
facehugger culture is worshiping her or
has turned her into some kind of leader
for some reason
you see the other aliens with the
facehuggers doting on her while she's
lounging on this chair
shouting orders at them to get rid of
rick and morty so either summer is
pissed at them for some reason or she
just totally goes off the rails during
the episode and winds up becoming this
demigod of these people
in the other trailer scenes maybe after
this moment here you see rick tell morty
that they have to wear
dead face huggers as disguises over
their faces to pass through the streets
on notice
probably to make their way to summer
then at some point later they're
completely
overtaken by the crowd and he calls out
his unnecessarily long anime suit-up
montage trope which is also a call back
to the purge episode with their iron man
suit up scene
morty
this time they animate the suit up
montage in the style of a classic
anime i believe this is specifically
meant to be a ronin warriors reference
because of the armored designs and the
swords that they're wielding
so presumably the outcome here is the
same as the purge episode when they suit
up and they just take everyone down
because their armor is so much more
advanced than everyone else
there's also the separate footage of
them flying through the area and rick's
ship with the facehuggers trying to make
it into rickship and then trying to
blast all these other alien bug-looking
ships
obviously all this background animation
is made to look like the alien queen
hive
from aliens so maybe summer is for some
reason their queen or deemed their queen
and just like they do every once in a
while they reveal more secret functions
that rick's ship has we find out that as
a secret gun turret that morty then uses
that aside though it's kind of hard to
tell if any of the other season 4
trailer scenes from last month
correspond to the episode 7 next week
you watch the trailer then you actually
get something like episode 6 and it just
completely throws everyone for a loop
with all the misleading trailer footage
in them not revealing all the
non-canonical scenes till you actually
watch the episode
don't worry morty nothing out there is
canon i'm not really expecting any more
episodes like episode six for the rest
of the back half of season four just
being so overtly meta on purpose
rick and morty is usually a show that
gets met every once in a while with some
particular jokes or scenes
but they don't always go really meta
purely for the sake of getting meta
episode 6 was just an exception to that
because they were using it to call out
bad storytelling bad writing and kind of
calling out bad fans at the same time
and you could say calling out capitalism
in the virus nobody's out there shopping
with this
virus they kind of dig into that during
the footage of dan harmon in the writer
of the episode or the credited writer
jeff loveness talking about how rick can
literally and metaphorically do anything
in how that can be a literal and
metaphorical trap for him as a character
and for the writers in the writer's room
so they wanted to do an episode
based around that as an anthology
episode but dan harmon also kind of
admits that the story train quote
unquote so to speak got away from them
in the writers room
so if you feel like last week's episode
went off the rails in a bad way that's
them sort of acknowledging that
i think for the most part people were 50
50. some people really like it when rick
and morty gets meta and some people like
more straight up narratives in episodes
for the most part i think the rest of
the season will be relatively straight
up there's always going to be big twists
in rick and morty episodes
but episode 6 was just an exception in
that every single moment was meant to be
a big twist
i saw a lot of you on my video for
episode 6 2 asking if
because they used evil morty and some of
the big twists like abradolf linkler
in such big ways saying they're
technically not meant to be canon
does that mean that we won't see any of
those characters again before the end of
season four
just like the writers say rick and morty
can literally do
anything any type of story any type of
twist so it doesn't necessarily confirm
that we won't see them again
but i think there were so many of those
moments and so many callbacks that i
am not really expecting any big evil
morty stuff before the end of the season
they did say there was some big season
five teaser post credit scene or some
big tease for season five at the end of
this season
but they didn't say what that was
originally i assumed it was going to be
some sort of canonical twist like
something about evil morty or the
citadel or
phoenix person jessica the galactic
government but if we're probably not
going to see any of those characters
again before the end of the season the
season 5 teaser could be
anything so leave all your theories in
the comments about what that teaser is
going to be
it is really funny to watch dan harmon
and that writer talk about how weirdly
afraid they are
of old men who were super ripped in the
logic behind their jokes about those abs
and how gross that got during the
episode dude i already did this i'm
terrified of old men
ripping off their shirts to show that
they've been training a lifetime to kick
your ass
jesus the tickets please guy is cut he
he's he's got those things oops
i'm gutters that's what people call them
what are they the grossest
phrase i've ever heard in my life
whatever that means i want it
the combination of the words disgusting
and yet something to aspire towards
it bespeaks of a volume whose is being
guttered
uh your own you are like 90 dumb gutter
i don't
where is it guttering to disgusting
you might think that that's weird and it
is kind of weird but those are the kind
of conversations that they devolve into
inside
comedy tv show writers rooms but i think
it's going to be really fun after
episode 6
trying to guess how accurate the titles
of the episodes are to what the actual
episodes are going to be
because sometimes they'll just have a
funny title that won't have anything to
do with what's going on in the episode
usually it does have some sort of link
to the theme of the episode though
that's another one of those games you
play with rick and morty like when
you're trying to guess
which scenes from the season 4 intro are
real and which ones are fake scenes
but i do like the theory that all the
scenes in all the
intros are real it's just as they
haven't gotten to those episodes yet
because they're obviously that 70
episode renewal so we're gonna get about
a hundred episodes of rick and morty
bare minimum
i didn't talk about it in my episode six
video but we actually did get
confirmation of another season
4 intro scene that is a real scene
because it's them fighting paul
giamatti's character with him just
punching them into the other realities
if they drop any more trailers for next
week's episode of course i'll do a video
for it but let me know in the comments
if there are any specific questions you
want me to address for the show or any
rick and morty bonus videos
there's a bunch of stuff happening this
week in a couple shows that are
premiering so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
those when i post them
congratulations renegade you're the
giveaway winner for my last big rick and
morty video please email me on the about
page of my channel so i can get your
contact details
everyone click here for my rick and
morty season 4 episode 6 video
and click here for my clone wars finale
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]